the best thing that's ever happened a
creep a black Christmas you burn
Jennifer Lopez hybrid zoomed in on its
butt I hit the tree okay these moves are
you can't what you can't see oh my god
oh my legs these moves
oh you freaking did it I got to the menu
I came in like a wrecking bad oh oh look
at this tiny box oh it's so tiny
oh I'm gonna call you tiny box Tim
you're gonna come with me on an
adventure tiny box
you guys are boned means another
exceptionally well hidden key right all
right dick give me your key are you
doing taking a piss on the wall smash
smash it's tricking me
it's fixies Trixie Hobbit Jilly this
isn't this isn't Gollum I don't know who
this is
but they have those Trixie abacus pull
it over my head you'll get to do that
cuz that was my face that a boy is that
a but is that a boy there's a pregnancy
there's a panda thing
oh hi dear hey oh oh it got away
whoo it's gonna be okay it's gonna live
to see another day maybe it's gonna
swallow there is it's a Oh Bob's over in
another area
time for my best Shakespeare Oh what
doth guilt lies in my heart it is burns
with more intensity than a thousand suns
I have killed my own brother of another
mother and he is now dead I cannot live
with my shame ergo I will blow myself
the [ __ ] up goodbye
this has been markiplier highlights
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video and you'd like to see more than
please leave a like to let me know links
to all the videos are available in the
description below so check them out and
if you have a video that you want to see
in a highlights reel later let me know
in the comments below thanks again for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye